in regards to the 10th anniversary of
game of thrones
a lot of people have been coming back to
reminisce over the highs
and lows of the show i'm someone who has
notoriously pointed out a plethora of
heartbreaking flaws that plagued the
show
and i wanted to make a ranking video
that instead of looking at the best
moments
looks at the worst moments for this list
i'll be diving into the depths of
utter stupidity so sit back and relax
as i take you through what i think are
the 25 most stupid moments in game of
thrones
number 25 the first line of season 8.
before going into this i had a handful
of honorable moments i could easily
contend for the 25th spot
but i think the first line sets a
perfect precedence for what you should
expect from season eight
that's terrible writing ensurings that
don't even understand the characters
they're writing for anymore
ah yes this is a show of comedy now the
game of thrones
sitcom a show where the two smartest
characters are making [ __ ] jokes
instead of intellectual conversations
that ooze dramatic tension
also for this list i don't want to
include a lot of dumb lines and i think
stupid or illogical actions within the
story carry much more weight than just a
line of dialogue
but this line i think is so stupid that
it damages your expectations for the
season as a whole
number 24 the defenseless citizens of
winterfell
hiding in the crypt when the enemy can
resurrect dead people
i'm putting this kind of low on the list
because i'm partially giving the benefit
of the doubt that this was just a
massive oversight
but i'm sorry jon snow did not mention
at any point during the war council that
the night king can resurrect dead people
isn't that the whole point of a war
council to discuss the different powers
and advantages that the enemy will use
to their benefit
you're my council council speak sense to
this
honorable fool and it seems like
resurrecting dead people is their
primary ability
so wouldn't it be smart to discuss that
and how they would use it
but nah let's just move everyone into
the crypt because it's a safe place
it's like hey let's go hide in the
graveyard during a zombie apocalypse
but overall this was a very easy solve
it required jon or bran to use the small
short of brain power they have left
the night king is obviously after bran
so all they really had to do was
evacuate the weak people here
number 23 daenerys losing even more for
fleet during the attack on casterly rock
the reason why this is so stupid is that
this happens right after they lose a
large portion of their fleet in the
prior episode through their surprise
attack on the greyjoys
you would think that this would make
daenerys even more aware and hesitant to
use her fleet
but in the next episode i guess he just
forgets about the iron fleet and they
get counter-attacked
also by looking at the map it makes no
sense at all to use your fleet to
transport the unsullied to casterly rock
they have to travel through so much
hostile waters that it practically makes
it a guarantee
for them to run into the iron fleet here
i know it would take a long time for
army to march to castley rock but at the
pace the season was going they would
make it there in half a day
especially since dany went from
dragonstone to highgarden with the
dothraki in half an episode for the
spoils of war
number 22 gendry being able to run all
the way back to the wall without
dying this is pretty straightforward
gendry
a man who has grown up in the south and
who has never seen snow in his life
is somehow able to run the entire
distance they traveled in a day
without dying like excuse me do you know
how hard it is to run in the snow
let alone running for the duration that
gendry managed to do
this is basically just an example of
terrible writing where david and dan try
to include danny to save
jon's expedition if they are going to go
that route then
why not have bran help with a raven to
monitor their situation
when anything goes wrong brian can just
immediately inform daenerys
but bran doesn't actually use his power
so oh well
number 21 varus telling jon that he's
committing treason
if varys has done any research or has
even been paying attention to what john
has been saying
and what his ideals are he should know
that jon snow is an honorable man
so why the hell would jon snow ever
support going against danny here
at this point in the story she really
hasn't done anything wrong to warn jon
snow to want to flip on her
like hey can you betray danny right
after she helped you defeat the night
king please
so varys is just pulling a massive hail
mary and asking john to be the king
instead of danny is just idiotic
he's basically signing his own death
certificate at that point
a master of whisperers is going around
telling everyone he's committing treason
give me a break david and dan surely
buffoons can write anything better than
that
oh wait it only gets worse from here
number 20
euron teleporting to the beach to fight
jaime
i know 21 was pretty bad but this moment
is so mind-bogglingly stupid
that it's like kicking you on the ground
when you already have food poisoning
from the bad writing
the bells was a terrible episode and
this is basically the cherry on top
euron stumbling around that cliffside
corner with his smug face just made me
want to turn off the episode
out of all the places to swim euron
chose that exact spot
at the exact time jaime was there what a
magical coincidence that led to one of
the best scenes from the episode
wow at the very least they could have
given us a half decent action scene
but nah it was just an incoherent mess
like the rest of the season
number 19 littlefinger giving sansa over
to the boltons
this is the only moment from season 5
that has made it onto this list
the reason why i placed this over
everything else so far is because of the
significance of how stupid this decision
was
i talked about how this ruined
littlefinger's character in my analysis
on season 5 of game of thrones
but i'll give a quick rundown on why
it's so stupid
firstly sansa just witnessed
littlefinger killing lysa aaron
so instead of getting closer to sansa
and bonding with her
littlefinger throws her over to the
boltons and alienates her
this inevitably leads to sansa not
trusting littlefinger
and her despising him which compels her
to turn on him in season 7.
also it doesn't really make sense for
littlefinger to try and ally with the
boltons given that the north hates
them they don't have the support of the
lannisters anymore and sanus is coming
to attack them
so ruining his relationship with sansa
for a potential ally with the boltons
was a terrible idea also by the way
this was a change made by david and dan
so i'm really not surprised
number 18 john wasting time and not
getting on drogon when they are
evacuating beyond the wall
for me this is a personal pet peeve this
whole moment comes across as jon snow
getting tunnel vision and wasting a
bunch of time
and because of that wasted time it
appears as though jon stalling is the
main reason why the night king had
enough time to kill vasirion
if jon just got on the dragon everything
would have been fine
but then even after jon wastes all that
time killing whites
he notices that something is wrong and
is like
guys we have to get out of here we know
we're waiting on you you idiot then
viserion dies and jon just stands there
looking menacingly
at the night king until he gets tackled
into the water
what the hell is going through jon's
mind here is it really that hard to get
on drogon
this whole moment just comes across as
being very forced so the night king
could have enough time to kill viserion
and so that jon could be left behind
to then be saved by uncle benjen this
entire execution was just so moronic and
it easily deserves to be number 18 on
this list
number 17 jon being surrounded by whites
and he somehow survives
so this all happens when jon snow's
dragon crashes
and he's forced to pursue the night king
on foot to which the night king
resurrects all the fallen comrades which
then surround jon
snow in this instance jon snow should
definitely be
dead there is no question about that
he's literally surrounded by
dozens of whites also by the way
this is what the whites were like in the
beginning of the season they're
literally running at the enemy
and now they're just slowly walking at
jon
the plot armor here is so painfully
obvious and the filmmakers just hide
this by shamelessly cutting away and not
even showing him cut down the dozens of
lights
david and dan didn't even have the
decency of showing us a badass
choreographed fight scene to show off
jon snow's fighting ability
to make this more believable but oh well
i guess
number 16 jaime charging danny at the
end of the sproles of war
and surviving this is another instance
of plot armor but this time
it comes with a larger dose of stupidity
in what world does jaime think he can
actually get close to daenerys while
she's right next to drogon
on top of it being a horse galloping and
making a lot of noise
this is by no means stealthy it's a
straight suicide run
you know it's bad when one of the most
brainless characters in the show
tyrion lannister is calling you stupid
for charging dany
it's honestly just ironic at this point
that tyrion is calling jaime an idiot
given all the stupid stuff he's done in
season 7
which we'll get to later in the list but
not only is his attempt at killing
daenerys mindless
he also happens to get saved at the last
possible second did dany or drogon not
see braun come in and save jaime
how did braum somehow carry jaime out of
the water with all of his armor
there's just so much about this moment
that doesn't make sense and it's just a
terrible ending to an otherwise cool
battle sequence
number 15 john charging ramsay's army
and surviving
wow would you look at that another
instance of jon having heavy plot armor
what a surprise
for this instance i think this is the
first main example where game of thrones
stopped being
game of thrones it just became a more
generic
action fantasy show that threw out any
sort of realism and logic
and any sort of consequences for
character actions
like oh jon made a massive mistake and
played into ramsay's trap
well eh it doesn't matter he survives
anyways and sansa saves the day
this is where people stop believing that
characters were actually in danger
if you look back at past battles you
fear for the well-being of the main
characters because they have to
outsmart the enemy to win but for battle
the bastards
david and dan resort to a deus ex
machina that saves the day
i would put this overall moment higher
on the list but it honestly just gets
worse from here
number 14 jamie and cersei dying to
bricks
i was contemplating putting this higher
in the list but it's whatever i guess
they were going to die anyways
it's just the way they did it was the
most underwhelming way you could kill
two primary characters in your story
and honestly just feels like a massive
joke literally every fan theory is ten
times better than what happens
jaime betraying and killing cersei nope
they died to bricks
arya killing cersei with the mask of
jaime nope
they died to bricks thank you david and
dan for ruining these two characters
throughout season 8 and not even having
the decency to write a half that out
ending for them
number 13 cersei not killing tyrion when
she hates him
for this moment i'm referring to the
ending of the last of the starks where
cersei is about to have her archers kill
tyrion
and then she doesn't all of a sudden
literally at the beginning of the season
she sends braun to go and kill tyrion
and jaime
then later on she has the chance to kill
tyrion and then
doesn't like why not i'm honestly very
confused
throughout the whole story she's hated
no one more than tyrion
and it's not like she's against killing
her own family or anything given that
she killed her uncle kevin during the
great sept explosion
it's just this whole drama of will she
won't she kill tyrion
is very stupid it partially makes sense
for why she didn't kill tyrion at the
end of season seven because she was
manipulating him
but here in season eight she doesn't
have a reason to not kill tyrion
so yeah i guess i'm happy elephant lady
is very consistent here
number 12 jaime saying he never cared
for the innocents
with one line david and damn were
somehow able to ruin an entire character
to be honest i never really cared much
for them
innocent or otherwise like do they even
watch their own show or even read the
books
i feel like any viewer of game of
thrones regardless of writing experience
could have done a better job than
writing that line
all you literally need to understand is
jaime lannister's motivations and what
drives his character
to put this simply david and dan jaime
killed the mad king and sacrificed his
honor to save king's landing and the
innocents
so what he now has never cared about the
innocents
literally the only reason why i could
see damon and dan writing this line
would be to make jaime more edgy for
whatever reason this is honestly very
hard to try and figure out because it's
so idiotic so i'm just gonna move on
number 11 the dothraki charging into the
whites
this may not seem as bad as the
catastrophic line that killed jaime's
character
but this whole moment with a dothraki
doing a leroy jenkins charge into the
whites
is on another level of idiocracy first
of all
in the war room briefing before the
battle jon says this
you can't beat them in a straight fight
so
why the hell do the dothraki charge here
did daenerys just change her mind off
screen or something
did all the dothraki suddenly get hyped
up when melisandre lit up their swords
and they decided to charge in that
moment
there's just a lack of answers here the
only thing that makes sense is the whole
spectacle over logic conundrum that the
later seasons ran into
just don't worry if this actually makes
sense because oh it looks cool
number 10 tyrion's plan to extract a
white from the north and show
cersei this plan is an absolutely
horrendous idea first of all
tyrion should know that cersei is very
selfish and in practically no scenario
which she helped the good of the realm
cersei knows that if the undead army
exists they will severely weaken
daenerys army
and then the tide would be more even so
why is tyrion and everyone else so
hell-bent on trying to convince cersei
that the undead exists
i mean technically she already knows
that the undead exists through qyburn
resurrecting the mountain
so why risk so much to potentially and
most likely not get her supports
the goal of this plane is so devoid of
logic and the way in which they carry
out the plan
is even more devoid of logic if you
really want to lead an expedition north
then why not take the dragons north
quickly abduct one of the undead and
then return to the dragon
apparently everyone just assumed that
they would somehow capture a white
without the entire army noticing
like oh there's no possibility that the
night king will pursue us
in that event they should have all been
killed but
oh wait i forgot plot armor yeah it's
also kind of funny that the whites wait
for the ice to re-freeze even though
they can technically swim
but i'm getting off topic here so again
this is just a stupid suicide mission
that accomplishes nothing
number nine arya getting stabbed
multiple times
wading through a dirty river and etc etc
she somehow survives
so for the prior points of plot armor
the characters generally didn't get
injured and were mostly left
unscathed but here arya literally gets
rolled and
stabbed multiple times that alone would
definitely kill the average character in
the earlier seasons of the show
on top of that she most likely infects
her wounds by traveling through a river
with a bunch of stab wounds
i think kal drogo would like to have a
word about his death after that bs
and then arya just walks around the city
bleeding out and then happens to find
the actor she's been stalking
who happens to know how to patch her up
oh my god how the hell is arya still
alive
it's hard to really care about these
characters anymore in dangerous
situations
because if they can survive that then
they can basically survive
anything which basically happens later
on when arya should have died multiple
times during the fall of king's landing
it just ruins the tension within these
action scenes when it becomes very
apparent that our heroes are unkillable
number eight everyone in winterfell
being surrounded by whites and surviving
this was really the only thing i was
looking forward to in season eight
the hope of actually having a good
action set piece where a lot of
characters die
because honestly what's the point in
having plot armor at the end of a story
but i was unfortunately wrong literally
everyone within winterfell was somehow
unkillable the audacity that david and
dan had to show
samuel on the ground being hugged by
whites and somehow surviving just
made me lose it the entire execution is
abysmally devoid of any form of logic
ah yes these characters can somehow
fight off hundreds of whites
and even when looking up close you can
see that the whites are intentionally
not killing the characters
if sir barristan one of the best
swordsmen in game of thrones couldn't
fight off like eight sons of the harpy
members
then i highly doubt any of these
characters can fight off a horde of
whites
especially sam the slayer actually
let that sink in for a second samwell
while lying down can take on a horde of
whites
while sir barrison can't even take on
more than eight masters
who have probably never touched a sword
in their lives
what a devastating joke that is
somehow david and dan made the most
intimidating antagonistic force in
television
seemed like an absolute joke within one
stupid moment
congratulations number seven
jon not taking cersei's deal and ruining
everything at the end of season 7.
jon at this point in the story is
basically just hard throwing
in the episode before this he refused to
get on drogon and should have died when
he got tackled into the ice cold water
and then he continues this hard throwing
attitude by not accepting cersei's
simple request
of a truce and did not choose sides of
the war
in return the king in the north will
extend this truce he will remain in the
north where he belongs
he will not take up arms against the
lannisters he will not choose sides
like okay that sounds pretty reasonable
and is actually a good deal
especially for the north cersei will
help out in the great war against night
king and then after
dany and cersei burst each other and at
this point one dragon can basically take
out the entirety of the golden company
and the lannisters
let alone having another dragon and the
full force of the unsullied and the
dothraki at the time
but no jon arny bentham is extremely
horny and needs to help in the fight and
deny
the truce everything they did to lead up
to that moment was literally for
nothing the sirion ask room danny has
two dragons anyways lol
although this whole scenario was
technically for nothing anyways because
cersei was never going to help them
but still from jon's perspective cersei
was going to help and he threw that away
from a viewer's perspective it's just
extremely frustrating because it makes
half the season feel pointless
number six arya coming out of nowhere to
kill the night king
how poetic and perfectly logical a
character who has literally nothing to
do with the entirety of the white walker
subplot somehow ends up killing the
night king
so poetic and no we can't have jon snow
kill the night king
his primary antagonist by the way
because that just doesn't seem right
she seemed like the best candidate
provided we weren't thinking about her
in that moment we hoped to kind of avoid
the expected and
jon snow has always been the hero the
one who's been the savior but it
just didn't seem right to us for this
for this moment
we knew it had to be valerian steel to
the exact spot where the
child of the forest put the dragon glass
plate also by the way
let's loosely connect this with a random
line melisandre said to ary in season 3
that is so broad that it applies to arya
killing literally anyone
and in that darkness eyes staring back
at me
brown eyes blue eyes
green eyes eyes you'll shut forever
are you serious david and dan this is
why you think
arya should kill the night king god this
is so stupid
on top of the whole execution of the
scene where ari just flies in like an
eagle screaming it's just
utterly nonsense talk about being an
assassin
in this moment if arya wasn't decked out
with plot armor she would have been dead
within a second
given that the night king would have
just snapped her neck immediately
but hey don't think about that this is a
great ending we're just being
ungrateful number 5
john killing danny and not getting
killed for it
this moment is a little more broad and
isn't extremely specific
but not only did jon survive drogon the
unsullied for some reason took him
prisoner
by the way this is in an episode where
grey worm is killing lannister soldiers
for breathing
they're telling me this revenge field
man who literally has nothing left but
serving his queen
daenerys would not kill jon on the spot
for killing his
queen literally the last thing he cares
about
dave and dan don't even bother giving us
a scene where jon gets captured
and hopes the audience doesn't question
why they wouldn't execute jon snow on
the spot
for drogon i don't know what the hell
happened there and i guess he was just
sticking at the john by destroying the
throne
which in of itself was a really weird
scene jon killed drogon's mother but
hey screw it i think we'll be even if i
destroy this chair
that sounds about right also not only
did jon snow survive drogon
and grey worm but he also survived the
dothraki
the fact that the dothraki blood riders
didn't even want to seek vengeance on
jon
is so painfully devoid of logic in
season six
daenerys named all the dothraki her
blood writers
and you would think that they want to
avenge their call but
hey don't think about it they just
disappeared and went back to essos
because they got kinda bored i guess
number four sansa not telling jon that
she has the support of the veil
this may seem a little high considering
the catastrophic damage some of the
prior points have conflicted from their
sheer stupidity
but i think this decision that sansa
made is single-handedly the second worst
decision made by a character in the show
so why the hell did sansa not tell jon
about the support of the vale
this seems like massive need to know
information for a battle
you had asked for my advice earlier i
would have told you not to attack
winterfell until we had a larger force
or is that obvious
when will we have a larger force we've
pleaded with every house that'll have us
the blackfish can't help us
let me stop you right there john i feel
your anger and frustration but for me
it's entirely directed towards the
mental lunacy that is
sansa so you're telling me that you want
to wait for a larger force when you
literally have
a larger force to attack with why is she
not telling jon here
it makes perfect sense to tell him in
this moment what she doesn't trust him
for some reason
her brother and an honorable man okay i
guess
jon is literally on the losing side of
the war and with this information they
could have easily won the battle
instead though by sansa intentionally
withholding this information
she creates so much unnecessary conflict
and almost indirectly kills jon
actually if the show still had
consequences for stupid actions jon
should have died in the battle
it also amazes me that jon isn't even
angry at sansa for not telling him about
the veil and how he almost
died if anything he compliments her for
bringing the veil
you're the lady of winterfell you
deserve it we're standing here because
of you
the battle was lost until the nights of
the vale rolled in they came because of
you
this whole situation just comes across
as very bad writing so dave and dan
could justify the stereotype of the
heroes losing a battle
and in the last moment they get saved
feels good man
this show prioritizes stereotypes and
action set pieces instead of logic
number three danny snapping and
destroying king's landing
honestly to a certain degree the
destruction of king's landing and the
ending of the mad queen arc
is a cool development but its entire
execution is so
painfully stupid like yay daenerys won
the battle and has seized king's landing
and they have surrendered yay
wait what is that she's getting
triggered all of a sudden and is losing
her composure and is now destroying
king's landing
what for me what lacks heavily in this
moment is an inciting
incident there's nothing that really
drives daenerys to go over the edge here
what would make more sense would be for
her to lose missandei during the assault
on king's landing
which would thus push her over the edge
ideally though they shouldn't have
killed sir barrison in season 5
and his death could have made her go
crazy in season 8 but
my point still stands for missandei the
whole destruction because of this
development seems completely
unjustified and the audience feels
extremely disconnected with daenerys
striker biggest moment in the story
this is why i think this stupid moment
deserves to be within the top three
because one stupid moment ruins one of
the biggest turns in the show
number two daenerys forgetting about the
golden company
and losing rhaegal to me not only is
this
extremely stupid but it's also the most
insulting moment in the show's history
you're telling me that daenerys forgot
about the iron fleet right after beerus
brought it up in their briefing
are you actually kidding me this is
david and dan's reasoning for killing
rhaegal
and then even right after killing
rhaegal the iron fleet just becomes
cross-eyed and misses daenerys when she
gets even closer to the fleet
also given within the context of the
show this is the third time they get
surprise attacked by the iron fleet
so i guess daenerys just doesn't learn
from her mistakes at all
how hard would it have been to scout out
the waters ahead of the dragons or even
with a few spare ships
also if you really need to kill another
one of the dragons to make the battle
more fair for cersei
then why not just kill rhaegal during
the long night
i think it would have been a much better
death scene if rhaegal fought the dragon
at the end of the long night saving jon
instead of jon just screaming at the
dragon but oh well
danny just kind of forgot about the iron
fleet
number one brand becoming the king
i think without a doubt this is the
number one most stupid moment in
all of game of thrones the pure
inconsistency of writing about how bran
didn't even want to be lord of anything
and then him all of a sudden wanting to
be the lord of the seven kingdoms
is in a different realm of idiocracy i
can never be lord of anything
i don't really want anymore why do you
think i came all this way
that's like jon snow constantly saying
throughout the season that he doesn't
want it
and then in the end he says triumphantly
he wants it
then we have the whole who has a better
story than brand the broken conundrum
why the hell is tyrion electing a king
off of the factor that bran has an
interesting story
tywin is probably molding in his grave
from the pure mindless stupidity that is
streaming from tyrion's mouth
those are the qualities that actually
make for a good king
not a comatose vegetable who has
literally no sympathy or empathy for
anyone he is dealing with
then we have the issue of bran having
the most interesting story
if tyrion actually took the time to
listen to the story of other characters
besides just bran
then i'd assume he'd actually have other
candidates to choose from
it's just ironic that the quote unquote
most interesting story comes from the
character who is missing from an entire
season of the show
man david and dan you really outdid
yourselves here with this scene
thank you for ending the show in the
absolute worst way possible
in setting the fans on a journey of
hatred for the final season of the show
[Music]
so yeah those are what i think are the
25 most stupid moments within the show
you may disagree with a few of them or
how i placed them but that's just
personally how i would rank them
if you enjoyed the video i would be down
to do some other ranking style videos
for game of thrones
and i'm definitely open to suggestions
have a great day and let me know what
you think is the most stupid moment in
game of thrones in the comments